Saben, los últimos días,
mientras me preparaba para mi discurso,
me ponía más y más nerviosa
por lo que voy a decir y por estar en el mismo escenario
que toda esta gente fascinante.
Estar en el mismo escenario que Al Gore, quien fue la primera persona por la que voté.
Y --
(Risas)
y -- me estaba poniendo muy nerviosa, saben,
no sabía que Chris se sienta en el escenario,
y eso es más estresante.
Pero después empecé a pensar en mi familia.
Empecé a pensar en mi padre y mi abuelo
y en mi tatarabuelo,
y me di cuenta de que
teniendo todos estos Teds
fluyendo por mi sangre -
(Risas)
- éste tenía
que ser mi elemento.
Así que ... ¿Quién soy?
Chris mencionó que fundé una compañía con mi esposo.
Tenemos como 125 colaboradores internacionalmente.
Si miraban el libro,
eso es lo que veían,
lo que realmente me impactó.
(Risas)
Como quería impresionarlos a todos con diapositivas,
porque vi las geniales presentaciones de ayer con gráficos,
hice un gráfico que se mueve,
y habla sobre cómo estoy hecha.
(Risas)
Así que, aparte de esta rareza,
esta es mi diapositiva científica. Esto es matemáticas,
y esto es ciencia, genética.
Esta es mi abuela, de quien heredé mi boca grande.
(Risas)
Entonces...
Soy una bloguera, lo que probablemente para ustedes
significa varias cosas.
Quizás oyeron el revuelo del candado Kryptonite,
cuando un bloguero habló sobre cómo
romperlo usando un bolígrafo,
y todo el mundo se enteró. Kryptonite tuvo que ajustar el candado
y tuvieron que referirse a ello
para evitar preocupaciones de los clientes.
Quizá habrán oído sobre Rathergate,
que básicamente fue el resultado de que
algunos blogueros se fijaran en las letras "th"©
en el número 111: como eso no se puede hacer
con máquina de escribir, está en Word.
Los blogueros hicieron público esto,
o se esforzaron por ello.
Saben, los blogs dan miedo. Esto es lo que vemos.
Si veo esto, de seguro me asusto
terriblemente con los blogs,
porque no es algo muy amigable.
Pero hay blogs que están
cambiando la manera en que consumimos noticias y medios,
y son ejemplos geniales. Estas personas están llegando a
miles de lectores, por no decir millones,
Y eso es increíblemente importante.
Saben, durante el huracán
el canal MSNBC posteó sobre el huracán en su blog,
actualizándolo constantemente. Esto fue posible
por la facilidad de las herramientas de blogueo.
Saben, tengo un amigo
que tiene un blog
sobre GPDs, grabadoras personales digitales.
Sólo con los anuncios gana suficiente dinero
para mantener a su familia en Oregon.
Eso es todo lo que hace ahora y
los blogs lo hicieron posible.
Otro ejemplo es Interplast.
Es una organización maravillosa de
personas y doctores que van a países en desarrollo
a ofrecer cirugía plástica a los que la necesitan.
Así, atienden a niños con paladar hendido
y documentan su historia en el blog. Es maravilloso.
Yo no soy tan caritativa.
(Risas)
Yo hablo sobre mí misma. Eso es lo que soy, una bloguera.
Desde siempre tenía decidido ser experta en algo,
y soy una experta en mí misma
así que escribo sobre eso.
Así que, esta es
la historia corta de mi blog: empezó en el 2001. Tenía 23 años.
No estaba contenta con mi trabajo,
porque era diseñadora
pero no tenía ninguna motivación.
Había estudiado inglés en la universidad. No lo estaba aplicando,
pero extrañaba escribir. Así que empecé a escribir un blog
y empecé a crear cosas como estas historias.
Esta es una ilustración de mi experiencia acampando cuando tenía 11 años
y fui a un campamento cristiano de la YMCA.
Al final había logrado que
mis amigos me odiaran tanto
que me escondí en una litera. No pudieron encontrarme.
Mandaron un grupo a buscarme y oí que decían
que ojalá me hubiera matado,
brincado desde la montaña Bible Peak.
Pueden reírse, está bien.
Esto es lo que me ha hecho ser yo, ésta soy yo.
Esto es lo que me sucedió.
Cuando comencé mi blog tenía una meta,
me di cuenta
de que no iba a ser famosa
para todo el mundo
pero podía ser famosa para gente en la Internet.
Así que me puse una meta: Voy a ganar un premio,
porque nunca había ganado un premio en toda mi vida.
Entonces me propuse ganar
el premio SXSW de blogs.
Y lo gané. Llegué a toda esta gente,
y tenía miles de personas leyendo sobre mi vida diariamente.
Después escribí sobre un banjo.
Escribí sobre
querer comprar un banjo
de 300 dólares, lo cual es mucho dinero.
Además, yo no toco instrumentos,
no se nada de música.
Me gusta la música y los banjos,
y creo que alguna vez escuché tocar a Steve Martin.
Así que me dije - ¡yo puedo hacerlo!
Le pregunté a mi esposo, ¿Puedo comprar un banjo?
Me dijo que no.
Éste es mi esposo, muy guapo -
se ganó un premio por ser guapo.
(Risas)
Me dijo,
"No puedes comprar un banjo -
eres como tu papá, que colecciona instrumentos"
Así que escribí
sobre lo enojada que estaba con él,
que fue un tirano porque no me dejó comprar el banjo.
Le gente que me conoce entendió mi chiste.
esta es Mena, así es como yo digo chistes.
Porque el chiste es que mi esposo no es un tirano,
es una persona tan amorosa y dulce
que me deja disfrazarlo
y poner fotos de él en mi blog.
(Risas)
Y si supiera que les estoy mostrando esto,
me mataría.
la cosa fue que mis amigos leyeron lo que escribí
y se lo tomaron a broma, ya saben,
tontear sobre querer una cosa estúpida.
Pero también recibí e-mails de gente que me decía,
¡Oh Dios mío!, tu esposo es un patán.
¿Cuánto gasta él en cerveza al año?
Podrías usar ese dinero y comprar tu banjo.
¿Porqué no abres una cuenta separada?
Estoy con él desde que tenía 17 años - nunca hemos tenido cuentas separadas.
Dijeron "Separa tu cuenta de banco -
gasta tu dinero y su dinero. Eso es todo."
Otros dijeron "Déjalo".
Así que
me pregunté ¿Quienes son éstas personas?
¿Y por qué están leyendo esto?
Me di cuenta que no quería llegar a esas personas.
No quería escribir para un público.
Y empecé a matar el blog lentamente.
Ya no quería escribir el blog,
y lentamente lo eliminé.
Contaba historias personales de vez en cuando.
Escribí ésta sobre Einstein hoy.
Se me va a hacer un nudo en la garganta, ésta fue mi primera mascota,
que murió hace 2 años.
Entonces tomé un recreo del "No quiero escribir mi vida en público"
porque quería hacerle un pequeño tributo.
De cualquier manera,
son estas historias personales. Saben, hay blogs sobre política,
o sobre medios de comunicación, chismes y todo eso.
Esos blogs están ahí, pero a mí me interesa
más lo personal - saben
ésta es quien soy.
Por ejemplo, los críticos de arte ven a Norman Rockwell
y dicen que no es arte.
Los trabajos de Norman Rockwell cuelgan en
salas y baños, y eso no es algo
que se considere arte.
Creo que esto es una de las cosas más importantes
para nosotros como humanos.
Este tipo de cosas nos conmueven.
Y si piensan en blogs, también piensan en los que son como arte,
como las pinturas histórias o las historias bíblicas,
y por otro lado tenemos esto.
Estos son los blogs que me interesan: La gente que sólo cuenta historias.
Una de esas historias es
sobre éste bebé llamado Odin.
Cuyo padre es un bloguero.
Estaba escribiendo su blog un día,
y su esposa dió a luz a su bebé
a las 25 semanas de gestación.
Él nunca espero esto.
Era un día normal y al siguiente era un infierno.
Era un bebé de menos de medio kilo.
Así que la vida de Odin fue documentada día a día.
Le tomaron fotos todos los días, día uno, día dos.
Por ejemplo el día nueve su padre habló del apnea,
el día 39 le dió neumonía.
Este bebé es tan pequeño,
y nunca encontré una imagen
que fuera
perturbadora, pero tan conmovedora.
Saben, estábamos leyéndolo mientras ocurría,
así, en el día 55 todos pudimos leer
que el bebé estaba teniendo dificultades respiratorias y del corazón,
y no se sabe qué esperar.
Pero después mejora. El día 96 se va a casa.
Y puedes leer sobre ello.
Esto no es algo que se vea en los periódicos o revistas,
pero es algo que esta persona está sintiendo
y la gente está emocionada al respecto.
Saben, 28 comentarios no es mucha gente,
pero 28 personas importan.
Hoy es un bebé saludable
-lo pueden ver si leen el blog de su padre,
es Snowdeal.org
Él sigue tomándole fotos, porque sigue siendo su hijo,
y creo que ahora está nivelado con su edad
porque ha recibido un tratamiento grandioso del hospital.
Entonces, los blogs.
¿Y qué? Seguramente habrán escuchado estas cosas antes.
Hemos hablado sobre well.com
y hemos hablado sobre esta clase de cosas
a través de nuestra historia online.
Pero creo que los blogs son básicamente una evolución
y ahí es donde nos encontramos hoy día.
Es un registro acerca de quién eres, la persona que muestras.
Es posible buscar en Google ¿quién es Mena Trott?
Y luego encuentras este tipo de cosas, y te hacen feliz o infeliz.
Pero también puedes encontrar blogs sobre personas
y esos son los registros de gente que escribe diariamente.
no necesariamente sobre el mismo tema, sino sobre cosas que les interesan.
Hablamos de cómo el mundo se hace más abordable y pequeño
y soy muy optimista al respecto.
Cuando pienso en los blogs, quisiera llegar a todas esas personas.
Miles de millones de personas.
Saben, ahora estamos entrando en China, queremos estar ahí,
pero hay tantas personas que no tendrán
acceso a escribir un blog.
Pero ver algo como la computadora de $100 USD es increíble
porque el software para bloguear es simple.
Saben, nosotros tenemos una compañía exitosa
porque llegamos a tiempo y perseveramos,
pero es algo sencillo, no es gran ciencia.
Eso también es algo asombroso a considerar.
Así que,
el registro de la vida en un blog es algo
que considero increíblemente importante.
Empezamos con una diapositiva de mis Teds
y tenía que añadirla porque sabía que
en cuanto mostrara esto -mi madre lo verá de algún modo,
porque ella lee mi blog-
y dirá: ¿Porque no había una foto mía?
Esta es mi madre. Esta es toda la ascendencia que conozco.
Esta es la parte
de la familia que conozco en términos
de mi línea directa.
Antes les mostré una pintura de Norman Rockwell;
yo crecí mirando esta pintura
constantemente.
Me pasaba horas mirando las conexiones.
Pensaba: "Oh, el niño pequeño del extremo tiene pelo rojo;
tal como la primera generación."
Y cositas como esa. No es ciencia,
pero era suficiente para mí,
para interesarme en cómo hemos evolucionado
y cómo podemos rastrear nuestra ascendencia.
Eso siempre me ha influenciado.
Saben, tengo este registro
del censo de 1910
de otro Grabowski. Ese es mi nombre de soltera,
y hay un Theodore, porque siempre hay un Theodore.
Pero esto es todo lo que tengo. Tengo un par
de datos sobre alguien.
Tengo su fecha de nacimiento, su edad,
su ocupación en el hogar y si hablaban inglés.
Y eso es todo lo que sé sobre estas personas.
Y es muy triste,
porque sólo puedo retroceder 5 generaciones
y eso es todo. Ni siquiera sé lo que pasó del lado materno,
porque ella es de Cuba y no tengo esa información.
Y para hacer esto pasé tiempo en los archivos
-también por eso digo que mi esposo es un santo-
pasé tiempo en los archivos de Washington,
sentada, buscando estas cosas. Ahora está online,
pero él me acompañó en mi búsqueda.
En este registro también
está mi tatarabuela.
Esta es la única foto que tengo de ella. Y pensar
en lo que podemos hacer con nuestros blogs;
pensar en la gente
que está en esas computadoras de $100 USD
hablando sobre quienes son, compartiendo sus historias personales,
es algo increíble.
Otra foto que me infuenciado en gran medida,
mejor dicho, una serie de fotos, es este proyecto
hecho por un argetino y su esposa.
Él toma una foto de su familia todos los días
desde hace... ¿qué es, 76'?
20, oh Dios mío, soy del año 77'...
¿29 años? 29 años.
Originalmente tenía una broma sobre mi gráfico, que dejé afuera.
¿Ven todas estas matemáticas? Estoy feliz de haber logrado hacerlas sumar 100,
porque hasta ahí llegan mis habilidades.
Así, tenemos a esta gente envejeciendo,
y así están hoy, o el año pasado,
y poder llevar este registro es algo muy poderoso.
Me gustaría tener esto de mi familia.
Se que un día,
a mis hijos, a mis nietos,
o a mis bisnietos -si algún
día tengo niños- les gustaría saber
qué es lo que hago,
quien fuí, así que hago algo muy narcisista.
Soy una bloguera,
que es algo increíble para mí,
porque captura un momento en el tiempo todos los días.
Tomo una foto de mí misma diariamante.
Lo he hecho desde el año pasado.
Y, saben, es la misma foto,
es básicamente la misma persona.
Sólo un par de personas lo leen. No lo escribo para una audiencia.
Ahora lo estoy mostrando, pero
me volvería loca si fuera realmente público.
Aproximadamente cuatro personas lo leen,
y me dicen que no lo he actualizado.
Probablemente tendré gente que me lo diga cuando no lo actualice,
pero esto es increíble, porque puedo ir a cualquier día
-puedo ir a abril del 2005-
y decir, ¿que estaba haciendo ese día? Lo veo y lo sé exactamente.
Es una pista visual, que es muy importante para lo que hacemos.
Y saben, también puse las fotos malas,
porque también hay fotos malas.
(Risas)
Y recuerdo al instante: estaba en Alemania,
tuve que viajar por un día.
Estaba enferma, estaba en un cuarto de hotel
y no quería estar ahí. Así pueden ver este tipo de cosas.
No siempre es sonreír. Ahora he evolucionado y tengo esta apariencia.
Si ven mi licencia de conducir
tengo la misma apariencia,
y es algo muy perturbador
pero es algo realmente importante.
Y la última historia,
realmente quiero compartirles esta historia,
porque es probablemente la que
significa más para mi respecto a lo que estoy haciendo.
Probablemente se me haga un nudo en la garganta, me pasas siempre con esto.
Esta mujer se llamaba
Emma y era una bloguera
con nosotros en TypePad. Ella probaba una versión beta,
así que estuvo con nosotros en cuanto abrimos
-saben, había 100 personas-
y escribió sobre su vida luchando contra el cáncer.
Emma escribió, escribió y escribió,
y todos comenzamos a leerlo, porque teníamos pocos blogs en servicio,
y podíamos leerlos todos.
Estaba escribiendo un día
y desapareció por un tiempo.
Su hermana nos contactó y nos dijo
que Emma había fallecido. Fue muy conmovedor
para todo nuestro equipo de soporte,
y fue un día muy duro en la compañía.
Y ese fue -
uno de esos ejemplos donde me di cuenta
de lo mucho que bloguear afecta nuestras relaciones,
y hace más pequeño este mundo.
Esta mujer estaba en Inglaterra
y vive, mejor dicho, vivió,
una vida donde pudo hablar sobre ella -
y lo que ella hacía.
Pero lo que tuvo una mayor influencia en nosotros
fue que su hermana me escribió
a través del blog y dijo que para Emma,
escribir este blog durante sus últimos meses de vida
fue probablemente lo mejor que le pudo haber pasado.
Haber sido capaz de compartir lo que estaba atravesando
y poder escribir y recibir comentarios.
Fue increíble saber que nosotros
permitimos eso, y que Emma se sintió
cómoda escribiendo en su blog.
Que la idea de escribir un blog no tiene que dar miedo,
que no siempre tenemos que atacar en los blogs,
y que podemos ser personas abiertas,
que quieren ayudar y hablar con otras personas.
Fue algo increíble.
Así que imprimí su blog, o, más bien,
envié un PDF de su blog a su familia,
y ellos lo compartieron en su funeral,
incluso mencionaron el blog en su obituario
porque había sido una parte importante de su vida.
Eso es algo tremendo.
Ese es su legado.
Creo que mi llamado
a todos ustedes es que
piensen en los blogs, en lo que son,
lo que han pensado sobre los ellos, y después
llévenlo a la práctica porque es algo que
realmente cambiará nuestras vidas.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)